είχαμε πάθει μεγάλις μια από την οκρανία που έχου μεγραφία και από τη ρωσία που
ανακαστήκαμε να αλίσουμε γραφί μας πάμε πίσως τα φάρμακα γιαατί κύρια πιθα θεόείτε πως κάποια
φάρμακα στη χώρα μας παρουσιάζουν μεγάλη διαφορά στην τιμή απότι το εξωτερικό αθα γυρίως είναι
ταφάρουμε κάτα οποία είναι τα λεγόμενα πρωτοτυπά των μεγάλων λεταιριών δεν νομίζω να ναφορά τόσο
πολύτα ομειοβραστικά ήταν γενόσημα φάρμακα είναιφάρμακα κάποιας ιδιαίτερης ας πούμε ψηλήστημης ο λόγος κατεμένα είναι
η μικρή ισχετικά μικρή κατανάλωση η κύπρος είναι μια μικρί αγορά πολύ μικρέγορα είναιδηλαδήδεν μπολί
να συγκρίνης την κύπρο με μια ούτε κάνμε τη ελάρα ηλαείναι δέκαποδικαφορες πιο μεγάλη αν
προσθέσουμε επίζη στην πολύ φαρμακία που υπάρχει στην είναι πολύ πιο μεγάλη από την κύπρο
περιστότερα ποδέκα και δοικα φορές η αυτό το λόγο αναγκάζονται και επειδή πρέπει ι σκη
συσκεβασία να αποκρίνεται σε κάθε χώρα με τη γλώσα της με τα ζητούμενα της καιλιπ
τα πωςα ι αριχθμοή μάλλων των συσκευασιών που έρχονται στην κύπρο είναι μικρότερη και αυτό
το πράγμα διατηρείτε στημές πιοψηλά είναι ένας λόγος ο οποίος υπάρχει αραγγάζονται να στέλουν με
ικρές παρτίτες και αυτό τ